this video provided by Keith police
shows officers shooting at drones flying
over the city in mid-october
the weapons can be seen in multiple
videos here the device knows dies and
explodes near residential buildings
several people were killed in the
attacks that day
dependent experts who analyze images
from Ukraine say Russia has been using
drones provided by Iran the Shahid 136
and its smaller version The Shaw head
131
foreign
Ukraine is calling for new sanctions and
Western countries say these drones show
Iran's direct involvement in the war
after initially denying it Iran
acknowledged sending some unmanned
aerial vehicles or uavs to Russia before
The Invasion Moscow has repeatedly
denied using the Iranian weapons but
there are three types of clues that
confirm their origin the design the way
they move and the internal components
found among debris by Ukrainian forces
first let's take a closer look at the
structure of the Iranian Shahid 131 and
136 they have a triangular shape with
wings and an arrow-like extension where
the Warhead is located
the weapons one of which is seen here in
Iranian defense Ministry footage are
self-destructing and designed for
one-time use meaning after a strike they
leave behind debris
these photos taken by the news agency
Reuters show drone wreckage after an
attack on a fuel storage facility in
kharkiv we asked analysts including a
drone expert from the American
organization's CNA to review the images
they said these markings likely
identification numbers are similar to
those that can be seen in Iranian
handoff footage of these drills the
debris found in Ukraine also have some
Russian lettering the letters can be
seen on the tips of the Wings which
appear to have the same shape and
structure as the Iranian drones
in addition to their appearance analysts
say the way Shaw had won 36 and 131
drones move is a distinct characteristic
here's that footage from Iran's defense
Ministry showing one of those drones
taking a sharp angle before hitting a
Target in a video posted to social media
from an October 17th attacking Kiev and
verified by the news agency storyfull
the Drone can be seen taking a similar
sharp tilt before it's obscured behind a
building
another video filmed in Kiev on the same
day shows a similar nose dive maneuver
before an explosion
key Clues can also be found by looking
at the internal components of these
drones
on the right side is a photo that
according to Israeli intelligence shows
the engine of the Shaw head 136 drone
being displayed in Iran in October 2014.
we couldn't independently verify the
image but analysts told us it looks
consistent with what Iran has disclosed
and on the left is a rotors photo that
shows an engine recovered from a strike
in Ukraine in October 2022 experts who
reviewed these images say they both
appear to be Mado md550s the model
that's used in Shaw head 136 Iranian
drones the copper colored rotors and
general structure are very similar other
internal components of drones found in
Ukraine can be linked to Iranian
manufacturers according to conflict
Armament research a private UK
organization that tracks illicit arms
and conflict zones
this panel seen in a photo of debris
taken at the site of a strike in Ukraine
contains the same layering of materials
as in other iranian-made uavs according
to the group
the group says this honeycomb meshing is
distinctive Iranian drones they've
documented
it's this part sitting between two
layers of fiberglass which is meant to
strengthen the body of the weapon
without adding too much weight other
Iranian characteristics include
handwritten serialization numbers and
stickers that can be seen on the same
panel said experts who viewed the
pictures
Russia says it uses its own germs in
Ukraine but none of the known models
mean in Russia have the same
characteristics as the Drone seen in the
key of strikes according to analysts the
only self-destructing drone of similar
shape that's produced in Russia is
called KUB it can be seen in this
Russian handout footage
Coupe drums couldn't be used in the
strikes on Kiev in October analysts say
because they can't travel farther than
roughly 40 miles and Russian forces were
stationed more than 100 miles away from
Kiev on October 17th in comparison the
Shaw head drones have a range of at
least 550 miles according to Iran
the cube is also smaller than the
drone's Ukrainian officials say were
found in Ukraine this still image of
Russian military footage shows the scale
of a cube whereas this is the size of
the drones found in Ukraine as seen in
footage from Ukrainian officials as well
as images of debris found in harkive
Ukrainian officials say Russia has
launched more than 300 Iranian drones
targeting civilian buildings as well as
Key Energy infrastructure causing
blackouts and concerns about heating
ahead of winter Keith says it was able
to shoot down many drones but is asking
for more help from the West
Russia's Ministry of Defense didn't
respond to a request for comment about
the use of iranian-made drones in the
war
[Music]
we're also working together to impose
sanctions on those supporting President
Putin's War
that includes Iran
the European Union has already imposed
new sanctions on Iran and the U.S has
hinted at more penalties in the future
but these attacks also highlight that
despite sanctions in recent years Iran
has built one of the world's most
successful drone fleets
[Music]